I want to introduce you to Elan Moy she
is a staff writer with the Washington
Post she covers finances particularly
consumers and the economy and she's here
today to talk with us about debt
settlement companies and some of the new
rules that those companies are facing
first of all miss boy what what are debt
settlement companies that companies are
a very particular part of the debt
relief industry and what they promise to
do is to actually reduce the amount of
debt that you owe to your creditors a
lot of other firms and nonprofits offer
to you you know reduce your interest
rate and reduce the amount of payments
they actually promised to reduce the
amount of debt that you owe and that has
come under a lot of scrutiny in recent
months are these for profits or not for
profits or both they tend to be for
profit companies some of the companies
that are involved in this type of debt
relief actually provide other services
as well but debt settlement is a
for-profit business and that's what's
caught the attention of many regulators
and you if you've ever watched TV or
listen to the radio you've seen one of
these this is a special announcement if
you have credit card debt please listen
a program has been introduced that could
reduce your debt
decrease the amount you owe and allow
you to make only one low payment each
month if you need relief from credit
card debt you may qualify for an
assistance program that can have you
debt free reducing America's credit card
debt is vital for our economy now you
have a choice we offer the successful
alternative to bankruptcy credit
counseling or taking on new loans
thousands of Americans have qualified
for this program saving over 100 million
dollars to date call for a free
evaluation now it's confidential and
just takes a few minutes to see if you
could join the program but it has a
limited enrollment call for an
evaluation now and get started towards
becoming debt free certified specialists
are available now who understand your
situation call for a free consultation
get relief and become debt free
bigger businesses this it is a very big
business at least it was a for some new
regulations took effect the companies
estimate that they've settled anywhere
between two about two billion dollars of
consumer debt the average consumer that
comes to them has about $30,000 in
credit card debt and there are roughly
about a thousand companies that handle
this kind of problem so if you call one
of these companies and do they all do
the same thing basically they do the way
that it works is you call a company and
you say I am saddled with credit card
debt and what they promise to do is to
reduce that amount of debt that you owe
to your creditors and the way that they
do that is they typically charge you a
sign-up fee to enroll into the program
they also charge you a portion of your
total debt that's owed so somewhere
between 20 percent of the amount of debt
that you owe they will take a service
fees a lot of times the bit on top of
the day a lot of times these service
fees are taken even before one debt has
been settled so again that's one of the
issues that regulators have been
consisting at with these companies so
what's the advantage to consumers to
going into these groups a lot of times
these consumers are really stuck between
a rock and a hard place there were some
changes to the bankruptcy law about five
years ago that really made it tough for
people who are under a crushing amount
of debt to file for bankruptcy maybe
they can't afford it maybe they don't
qualify anymore and so they're really
looking for another avenue to take care
of their personal finances and that's
when this type of industry began to
blossom so for the consumer they're
looking at it as a possible way out
maybe have to pay somebody twenty
percent of my debt but if I can
negotiate to get 50 percent of the debt
that I owe reduced then it's a good deal
for me at the end of the day how many of
these debt settlement companies are
sponsored by the credit card companies
they're typically independent of the
credit card companies I'm permanently
financed independently financed
independently run there were some issues
a few years ago with the relationship
between credit counseling firms and
credit card companies but this is a
different animal entirely these are
businesses that are that are looking to
do this on their own and in some cases
according to regulators taking advantage
of consumers what are some of the new
rules and just took effect this week all
right so this week the FTC has
that debt settlement companies must now
let you know how much the entire program
is expected to cost and they have to
give you a good idea of how long it's
going to take to go through this program
sometimes they promise you can do this
in as little as three years but the
reality is it can stretch out for much
longer than that so they have to be more
transparent in their practices starting
next month they're going to begin
banning advance fees in the industry and
that's something that's very
controversial that the industry says
could mean the end for many companies
and that basically how do the companies
make their money then well that's if
they're not charging a fee exactly
that's the that's the argument of the
industry they say that actually taking
on a lot of these customers with thirty
thousand dollars in credit card debt
typically have very broken credit
histories is very difficult and very
expensive for them you can cost up to a
thousand dollars for them just to get
somebody to sign up and to sort of
handhold that person through the process
so they're saying this is very expensive
and that they need the advance fees to
survive that's a good question what will
happen once those advance fees are
banned
we may see some companies go out of
business there are a few that say we can
still continue to operate and maybe rely
on some other types of revenue streams
and services in order to make up the
difference
how many companies debt settlement
companies are there in the US how many
clients were they serving yeah the
number of clients is difficult to say
because some people sort of fall in and
out of the program but the industry
groups estimated there are about a
thousand companies that are operating in
this arena and they've settled at
roughly two billion dollars worth of
consumer debt well if there's a thousand
companies operating in this arena there
must be a lot of money to be made well
that's that's one thing that that
they're they are hoping to do and that's
another reason why the regulators really
began looking at them there were some
companies that were operating as
legitimate firms but this is an arena
that really is sort of rife for fraud
and and there were several cases that
have been brought against debt
settlement companies FTC has brought
seven against them and this is one an
area they wanted to crackdown on we are
talking about the debt settlement
companies and new rules that go into
effect this week and Ilan Moy is our
guest she is with the washington post
202 is the area code 737 triple zero to
four
mccr at 7:37 triple zero one for
Republicans and six to eight zero two
zero five for independents plus we've
set aside our fourth line this morning
if you have been or are a debt
settlement client we would like to hear
your story two oh two six two eight zero
one eight four is the number for you to
call we're going to begin with a
Democrat in Houston Texas go ahead
kenneth you're on the air just come on
how you doing good morning yes i want to
know about the reverse mortgage it's you
know for the elderly people when they go
and they they go and they get the Mokpo
i don't come these government programs
are they private programs well that's
hard to say without knowing a little bit
more information about your about the
situation i will say that one of the
issues that regulators been trying to
crack down on is this idea that some
some companies are trying to align
themselves with the government bailout
programs and trying to sort of persuade
consumers that they're more legitimate
and they offer good services because
they're somehow aligned with these these
government subsidies and government
stimulus packages so that's something to
be very very careful about in fact for
the debt settlement industry that is one
area in which the FTC and the general
the GAO has has deemed them for is sort
of insinuating that they're involved
with government programs when they're
really not so it's something that I
would be very careful about and these
are not these debt settlement companies
are not government programs
they are not government programs there
was a an investigative report by the GAO
that came out earlier this year that
found some of them sort of claimed that
they they were a part of government
programs even maybe had some federal
seals on their websites but actually
this is not anything that's funded by
the federal government at all next call
on debt settlement programs comes from
let's see we've got Weatherford Texas
Andrae go ahead yeah how y'all doing
this morning
I think mr. mr. muy muy muy muy I think
what you failed to tell that callers is
some of these debt settlement companies
you have to have over $10,000 in debt
or they even take you on as a client and
then they fail to tell you that well
that I don't want to give anybody any
publicity so I won't say the company's
name that I talk to but you can call
your creditors yourself and you can
negotiate how'd it go I $140,000 in
medical expenses I negotiated myself six
cents on the dollar and they stopped my
interest and they stopped the interest
and I'm still paying on it now but a lot
of these companies won't accept you
because they won't make any profit
unless you got $10,000 worth of debt or
more right that is a very good point
these these sorts of programs are
designed for people with excessive
amounts of debts this is not something
you know if you have three thousand four
thousand dollars in credit card debt
they're designed for people who are in
extreme situations the other point that
the karlon made is also very good you
can do this yourself a lot of times you
know you can pick up the phone call your
credit card company and tell them that
you're in a tough situation and you may
be able to work out a deal what the
companies will say what the industry
will say is that a lot of people who are
in the situation they don't have that
capacity they don't have that knowledge
for how to negotiate and how to handle
their finances and so that's where these
companies are stepping in to help them
out joining us now on the phone is David
Luther hold he is the executive director
of the Association of settlement
companies mr. Luther hold these new
regulations that we've been talking
about that are going into effect what's
your view of these well we recognize the
need for a good view of the regulations
in fact our association task was has
required the types of disclosures and
standards that the FTC is recommending
the one aspect that we really don't
agree with is that what's called the
advanced fee ban which was mentioned a
little bit earlier where we can't
collect any fees until we settle a debt
and of course we can't settle the debt
for a consumer until they have enough
money saved up so that we can actually
negotiate with a creditor and get that
money over to the creditor so it puts us
in a position where we're
providing services month after month
after month for consumers but not
receiving any payment for it
Elan Moy do you have any questions for
David Luther hold of the association of
settlement companies right well what I
would say is that there are some
companies that are operating the space
that actually do do not operate through
advanced fees they operate through
receiving a portion of the amount of
debt that has been settled at the end so
sort of receiving their money on the
back end so I guess I would ask how do
you feel about these companies and can
the industry survive under that kind of
model yeah there have been a few
companies that say they operate under
that model but frankly every one I know
of this says that is only providing that
type of C program to a limited number of
clients I know of no company in the
country that has started from scratch
and actually been on that type of fee
model successfully from the very
beginning most of these companies that
have been providing some sort of feed to
themselves based on how much they say
the client have also been charging a
monthly fee along the way which is one
thing that we were to really love to
have to be allowed to be able to do but
again the companies I know of that are
that are now operating on that basis are
only doing so on a partial basis and of
course we're all going to have to do
that you know starting the end of
October so it's going to be really
interesting to see how many companies
are able to effectively manage that
process effectively profitably already
we've seen a good number of companies
that have decided and realized they
can't afford to continue on that basis
and have gone out of business mr. Luther
hold what about the rule that you tell
customers up front this is what it's
going to cost do you think that's only
fair Oh totally and in fact you know
that's one of the reasons that I helped
co-found tasks back in 2005 is we
realized that there was a need for
standards for companies operating in the
business and rates in the very beginning
that we've required
that ik that exact disclosure to be made
to every single client that's been
signing up into one of our programs so
and finally what what's the advantage to
going to a company like one of your debt
settlement companies rather than as Elan
moisted calling the credit card
companies yourself well some people may
be able to do it on their own and some
certainly can maybe with one creditor or
two most of the people coming under our
program have six or seven creditors and
in fact even the NCL see the National
Consumer Law Center in a study they did
several years ago looked at the question
as can a consumer actually settle the
debts themselves what they find as is
they can't they did find that some
consumers would have a creditor would
say okay you know I'll settle your
$5,000 debts for $3,000 but we want
$1,500 today and $1,500 in 30 days so
what they found was the repayment terms
really were pretty impractical now does
your group do you do these companies
sell to the credit card companies okay
do they sell them in bulk like mortgages
or sold no most of the settlements we
make with credit card companies are on a
one individual one-by-one basis there
are some companies we deal with where
we're able to maybe deal with you know
maybe a hundred accounts at a time but
even those accounts have to then be
handled each and an integral individual
basis by the settlement company once the
creditor company agrees to the final
settlement amount and are you or any of
your company sponsored by the credit
card companies no not at all all private
we're the only true independent industry
that just represents the consumer one
hundred percent we're funded totally by
the fees that consumer pays to us David
Leuthold of the Association of
settlement companies thank you for being
on the phone with us thank you next call
for Elan Mori comes from Philadelphia go
ahead Philadelphia Edward yes good
morning I don't know how these credit
card
companies that really to survive the
country's full of deadbeats liars and
drug addicts and no matter what
agreement you make with them they're not
going to pay anyhow that's what I see
you know but not only that they're
bragging about beating the credit card
companies that has been actually an
issue for the credit card companies over
the past few years the charge off rates
which is sort of the rates of people who
are no longer going to be paying their
debts have increased dramatically in
fact at some point they were up to ten
and even twelve percent and that is cost
the credit card companies a lot of money
and it's something they're not very
happy about but it's also forced them to
sort of restrict the amount of credit
that they give out to people I mean
technically people who are in more risky
financial situations what what
percentage of credit card holders go
into debt or go into default do you know
well in terms of going into going into
sort of that charged-off where you know
it's pretty clear that you're not going
to get any money out of this person
that's about right now about six or
seven percent somewhere around there so
the amount has increased and that's why
I think there's been a lot of attention
to these kinds of programs because we
really are in a time when consumers are
realizing that this spending boom that
they enjoyed in the earlier part of the
SEC aid is really coming to an end and
now they're sort of facing all the bills
and facing the amount of debt that they
have accumulated in the past several
years and realizing I can't pay it all
and so that charged off as you called it
that charged off percentage has
increased during this economic time
during the last couple years definitely
that has been one major reason that the
credit card companies are saying that
they have lost a lot of money it's one
major reason also why the amount of
credit that America has outstanding has
fallen by something like a hundred
million dollars over the last year next
call for Elan Moy comes from Fort Myers
Florida go ahead Carl yes I've been on a
debt management program for a few months
now and I'm very happy with it
the one I am with is what part of the
United Way and they didn't reduce my
balances but what they do is they took a
lot of my interest
went from like 20 30 percent dances like
1% in zero so I'm saving a lot of
interest and I'm very happy with it
are you making progress on your debt oh
yes yes I make one payment a month I've
closed I have no more credit cards up
close you have to close all your credit
cards and I make one payment to them
they charge me a $30 month fee all right
now when you say United Way are you
dealing with a non-profit are you
dealing with an actual for-profit
company I deal with and so they charge
you $30 a month correct United later yes
okay and what's gonna cost me what the
fees were and everything all right what
they do they negotiate with each credit
company and set up a payment program
with them where they have less interest
you learn more okay well I'm so glad
that he's making progress on his debt
that's fantastic to hear but the
important thing that he said was that he
was able to work with a non-profit to
negotiate down his interest rate that is
a different type of business and that
business is typically called debt
management or credit counseling what the
debt settlement companies do is actually
reduce the amount that's owed so it's a
very fine line and kind of difficult to
understand but they really are two very
different animals is it different than
you've seen the commercials you know if
you're having trouble with the IRS call
us because we'll get your debt cut down
to zero is that a different animal as
well it's hard to tell because the
commercials I feel are purposely
ambiguous so you're not really clear on
what exactly they're offering so you
know without calling it's hard to say
but frequently both debt settlement
companies and credit counseling
companies and debt management companies
everyone in this arena does advertise
over the radio on TV etc what if you go
into a debt settlement company how does
that affect your credit rating well and
they would say that industry would say
that it could actually help your credit
rating because if you actually pay off
your debts then you're gonna be in
better shape than you were before but
one concern that has come up is that
during this process some debt settlement
companies have instructed their consumer
their customers not to pay their
creditors during this process to wait
save up enough money and just make a
one-time payment and say this is all
you're gonna get so that's also caused
some controversy as well because any
time you stop paying your bills that can
hurt your credit score next call comes
from Houston Kenneth go ahead hey
Kenneth you know the rules you got to
turn down the volume on your TV we're
gonna move on to San Francisco Kim San
Francisco go ahead yes good morning and
thank you for this program I am and one
of the few people who have actually made
it through the mortgage modification
process and I've also been in a debt
resolution process with Everest debt
solutions since November of Oh 8 and I
put about ninety four thousand dollars
worth of unsecured debt into that
program and as of right now I'd paid
down to about forty eight thousand
that's great congratulations and I've
been very pleased with them their
payment yeah there was expensive
obviously I out the money obviously I
wanted to make it right obviously I
wanted to try to do it without
bankruptcy so you know still wondering
about that cuz you know some of the
bottom-feeder lawyer companies get a
hold of some of the lower you know the
some of the fruit that nobody will
negotiate on and then they get start
suing you and that's that's where I
start running into a into the problem is
I'm not equipped to deal with that kind
of venue I'm not a lawyer I don't know
how to go in and be pro per and
represent myself so that that's
presented a bit of a challenge but I've
been very happy with these ever said
solutions they've really really helped
me reduce this load almost well about by
half now
now Kim is when you say it's unsecured
debt was that mostly credit card debt
yeah I had tried to I have a successful
company that I've been doing for thirty
years but there was a local leather
goods company manufactured beautiful
american-made products the stores were
Native American it was All American and
I realized as I was financing it myself
with my house and all that they were
throwing money at me I mean I believed
in green grass and high tides forever I
thought we were doing all a great thing
American sorry you just don't want to
buy American even if it is reasonably
priced you know want quality you want
cheap stuff from overseas fine you got
it and so I had to let it go and try try
to save myself No did you consider
bankruptcy and how is this being in this
program affected your credit rating well
let's say my 780 is long gone
but at the same time so is everybody
else's I mean there's gonna have to be
some huge reset for credit scores anyway
because I'm sorry I'm so not alone
they're gonna have to figure out how to
solve this on a bigger scale than
they're that they're thinking too small
I mean that it's a big problem I am so
not alone thanks for calling in and
sharing your experience I think that
what this caller's situation really
demonstrates is that the bigger question
and the debate over debt settlement
debate over payday lenders check cashers
any of these sort of alternative
financial firms is a question of access
so you know we as many people look at
these companies and say should they even
exist why do people have all of this
debt etc etc but you know some folks are
in a really tough situation and what are
the services that are going to be
available to them to help them in their
position and what you got so many
companies would say is that they're you
know along a continuum of services for
people who are in tough spots and if the
companies go away who's going to help
them well the new FTC rules that are in
place for debt settlement companies
include they must disclose how long it
will take to see some results how much
it will cost consumers potential
negative effects of using debt relief
services and key information about
accounts must be disclosed Linda sherry
is with the Consumer Action Group
Linda sherry are you supportive of these
new rules and do they go far enough in
your view yes I am extremely supportive
of these new FTC rules on debt relief
and my organization has been working in
concert with some other consumer groups
for many years to try to get rules such
as this path to protect consumers
and when it comes to advanced fees are
you opposed to those yes advance fees
are a system in which the companies take
their money upfront and you know based
on information from industry
associations from the industry itself
nearly two-thirds of enrolled consumers
who had paid in advance dropped out of
the programs within the first three
years and didn't even see any benefits
from the program so if the industry's
own you know figures you're showing this
kind of thing we feel like this is a
program that does not help family
finances it erodes family finances Ilan
Moy with the Washington Post is on the
set here with me Ilan muy Linda I would
say do you what would you suggest for
consumers who find themselves in this
tough spot and and what would you
suggest them to do if the debt
settlement Avenue is not available to
them well even I would say that the debt
settlement Avenue has not even been
available to them before the FTC passed
these rules because it has been a sham
and does not really help that many
consumers so what we've told consumers
all along is that nonprofit credit
counseling agencies have tools to help
them handle their family finances for
instance they can go into one of these
credit counseling agencies on profit I
will reiterate and they will find that
they have budgeting services so they can
take a look at their overall financial
picture and see what is really happening
here and what next steps if necessary
they can then enter a debt management
plan with these agencies and the fees
are very low and usually on a sliding
scale according to income so they will
not divert important family income in
trying to solve their debt problem are
you satisfied with how the FDC Linda
Sheree has pursued settlements against
debt settlement companies and pursued
action or would you like to see it
stronger
I think the FTC has done a great job
it's been very aggressive in going after
some of these companies I think they
really understand that that many of
these companies are really skirting up
there
a fine line between hurting folks and
you know certainly not helping them as
the industry claims their there are
clear aspects to the FTC mission here in
that they are you know often use
deceptive advertising that the FTC
recognizes this and has targeted this
industry justifiably so
Linda sherry is with the Consumer Action
consumer group thank you for spending a
few minutes with us Tom and Annapolis
independent hi morning thank you for
taking my call wonderful program great
information good situation about me I
started with maybe thirty thousand
dollars more in debt two years ago I
tried that management it didn't seem to
work I tried credit counseling my
monthly balance would have gone up cash
flow out of pocket I eventually settled
with every one of my creditors to shut
down the accounts dress we reduce my
interest rates and I've been plotting
along but I in a position where I may
have to deal with this both pay off and
one thing you haven't mentioned and then
I actually have an idea for a compromise
here but one thing you haven't mentioned
is the fact that when you take a debt
settlement reduction either through one
of these companies or a negotiators on
your own that benefits that reduction in
your debt it's counted on your taxes so
then you have to pay tax on that which
further affects your out-of-pocket after
the whole thing is said and done and
I've had friends do this thing they
didn't realize that upfront but what
about putting this money in escrow when
you make your monthly payments instead
of you know you have to stop and by the
way every time I did this with an
institution they told me I wouldn't be
eligible for the program until I was
delinquent so that's kind of common but
why not put that in an escrow so that
the company doesn't get it as an upfront
fee but yet it's still there for the
consumer to pay down when it's time what
about that that you had a lot of
information there in the question um one
thing I would address first is the tax
issue and that is something that that
has been talked about there has been I
think some folks talking about potential
legislation around whether or not you'd
have to pay taxes on any amount of debts
that you don't pay that's an open
question the other thing that that
mentioned is this idea of an escrow
account and actually when you work with
a debt settlement firm they require you
typically to set up an escrow account
under which you deposit money where you
save up to pay off your creditors one of
the concerns about these escrow accounts
these third-party accounts is that
typically the debt settlement firm may
have access to that account and may be
able to take out their fees from the
amount of money that you're putting in
there before you are able to save up
enough money to pay off your creditors
so the third-party account has been
something that has cost many consumer
advocates restless night sleep New York
City go ahead hello you're on the air in
New York City go ahead yeah question
oh yeah Moy yeah do um when you're in
your field so you deal with like I've
seen that to add you guys but it was
Freedom Debt Clock there's also a
freedom tax relief office does that - we
fall under the same the same bike
settlement that the settle come
settlement company that the tax relief
company phone that they all fall into
the same regulation well it's again it's
hard to say without knowing exactly what
freedom tax relief court is but if they
are promising to reduce a consumers debt
and reduce the amount of money that they
owe they could very easily fall under
the same program as well next call for
Elan Moy talking about debt settlement
companies and new FTC rules that they
are facing comes from Colorado
go ahead Gregg hello hi I I just like to
say that I'm glad I was able to get
through I just got through working with
a debt settlement company and what was
your experience well one of the things
that I wanted to mention was I guess
when you're dealing with several dead
companies or credit card companies that
I think they're all on their own
separate schedule on terms of
well how they're managing your credit
card debt and I've noticed that some of
the companies are starting to send out
settlement offers which for which I
received like four or five settlement
offers in the mail which kind of was one
of the reasons why I got into the debt
settlement program did you did you
respond to the debt settlement offers I
mean did you say yes I'll take this or
did you say no well I was under the
impression that that was kind of
something that these debt settlement
companies would would do that was and so
what's been your experience now that
you've been working with the debt
settlement companies you received offers
from your credit card companies you went
to the debt settlement companies what's
been your experience well I the company
is specific company that I worked with
the way that they were set up was as
long as you get money in their account
that they can't actually settled until
you've reached a certain amount of money
in your account before they actually
call up the credit card company yes
again this is very standard this is the
third party escrow account that we're
talking about previously and the way
that that works is again there's a
there's a separate account that's set up
and what the debt settlement company say
is hey you need to save up X amount of
money before we can even go to your
creditors with some kind of reasonable
offer the question is how difficult is
it for consumers to save up that extra
amount of money and how much of that
money is going to go toward fees and how
much is at the end of the day going to
go to the credit card company the other
concern with that is is while you're
saving up the money another caller
mentioned this as well
frequently credit card companies will
not agree to negotiate with you if
you've paid your bills on time what is
them to do they have so there is some
strange disincentive to actually not pay
your bills which is something that can
get you into trouble down the line but
again a lot of times they're not willing
to help you unless you are
troubles there's a chicken-and-egg there
have the credit card companies ever
publicly spoken about the debt
settlement companies have they said
anything pro or anti about these
companies not that I'm aware of however
the credit card companies will say that
they work with our customers on an
individual basis to at times work out
debts and work out payments so that
again that Avenue is available to you if
you have the financial sort of literacy
to to negotiate with them next call for
Elan boy comes from tampa mary
republican hi iran i'd like to hear your
comment on my situation if you could
please I'm unemployed and I have not
been able to find a job to do at that
settlement I've been offered settle many
settlements but they want like big
payment within two months and not having
a job I'm actually in foreclosure
Wednesday I applied for a temporary job
and they were going to hire me for
through the holidays minimum wage Friday
Saturday and Sunday four hours each day
12 hours a week should be about 120
dollars a week and then they called me
yesterday and they weren't able to hire
me because my credit is bad this is the
8th time I've been denied a job that the
employer was willing to give me a job
and they told me no they can't hire me
because my credits bad and I've tried to
contact my legislators here in the state
of Florida and nobody seems to listen to
marijuana I hope I don't know what to do
well she is in luck that there is some
legislation that's out there and I
believe has passed this is not as an
area that I mess up on there has been
legislation out there about this very
issue about how our credit reports
impacting people's ability to get jobs
and whether or not employers are
considering that during the hiring
process clearly this woman feels that
that has impacted her ability to get a
job but that's something that Congress
has looked at and something that if it
hasn't passed yet I'm sure we'll have
but more about
Future Virginia Beach Curtis Democrat oh
I wanted to know about your local bank
or credit unions and if they have
counseling credit counseling and if it's
a if a bank that you hold a card with is
it a conflict for them to counsel you on
your credit debt when they hold a credit
card yeah I would tell you that um it is
important to call up your creditor when
you start to get in trouble if that
would be my very first step I'm
obviously not a financial adviser but I
would say that that's the first thing
that you should do is to call up your
credit card company or call up your bank
and say I'm having a problem what can we
do and that's where I would start before
I go down some of the other roads they
have a lot of these debt settlement
companies popped up or been formed in
the last two years because of the
economic crisis that we're having if
about a thousand companies are in this
business have a lot just come online
yeah actually um the association of
settlement companies we spoke with
earlier when they were formed I think it
was about 2003 there were only about 300
companies in the space that has
increased to a thousand companies now
you so you can see there's been a lot of
growth in recent years really the
business began to increase after changes
to the bankruptcy law made it difficult
for people for people to go into
bankruptcy and then the financial crisis
sort of added on to that as well who are
where are some of these debt settlement
companies based well we have two very
large debts one when companies actually
based in the Washington area there are
two that are based in Maryland that I
they know of that provide services to
many people but they really are all over
the country and they are basically
essentially Private Finance ears who
start a company yep that's exactly it
they may have been offering some other
type of financial services previously
maybe offering credit counseling maybe
offering some of these other plans that
we were talking about along eye
continuum and then added that settlement
to their array of services you know more
recently st. Petersburg Jeff
Republican hi good morning my name is
I'd like to find out a little more
information or advice for us to give our
young people and especially young family
members that have all sudden found
themselves in debt and you kind of want
to go the ethical well you have to pay
your debt off at the same time you know
it seems like the bank's had a lot of
predatory lending practices towards the
young people so you try to get them to
pay it off or they eventually going to
fall so far behind but the interest that
they're kind of stuck between a rock and
a hard place yeah that has been that's a
very good question and actually there
have been a number of protections around
all types of lending that Congress has
enacted in the past two years so one of
them that is specifically tardy
targeting young people is around student
credit cards that was packed as part of
the credit card Act that limited the
marketing that students that credit card
companies could do on college campuses
limited sort of the the way that
colleges and credit card companies could
interact force is forcing colleges to
release any contracts they might have
with credit card companies so there are
things that are happening on a national
scale to help protect some of the most
vulnerable consumers out there Elan
Moi's with the Washington Post and she
has been with us talking about debt
settlement companies and some of the
FTC's new rules regarding such companies
thank you and please come back thank you